اهلا من جديد كل شيء بالحياه له ثمن
والشهره والمناصب مش دائما بتجيب لنا
ارباح لهم ماسك بسنه 2022 كان من الاسماء
المتصدره الاخبار
بشكل يومي لكن يبدو انه السنه ما كانت
منيحه ابدا ابدا عليه فبعد ما كان الرئيسي
تنفيذي لشركه تسلا اي لون ماسك ثاني شخص
في التاريخ المعاصر عنده ثروه شخصيه بتزيد
عن 200 مليار دولار شهد لهم ماسك انخفاض
حد بثروته 137 مليار دولار بس بعد
التاويسهم شركه تسلم الاثريه الاخيره هذا
الانخفاض يا جماعه كان من ذره ثروته
البالغه 340 مليار دولار في الرابع من
نوفمبر 2021 بعد ما ضل اغنى شخص في العالم
لانه عامين عموما ما بدنا نساوي اكيد حسب
التقارير اللي تكلمت عن الموضوع السبب
الرئيسي وراء اللي صار مع هو طبعا انشغاله
التام بتويتر بالفتره الاخيره واللي منذ
استحواذ ماسك عليه بيواجه تخبطات وعواصف
ورياح من قراراته المفاجاه ثانيه واحده
خلت ماسك اول شخص يخسر 200 مليار دولار
بالتاريخ عموما يبدو ان سنه 2023 ما راح
تكون احلى للاسف على ماسك من 2022 والسبب
انه شركه تويتر بتواجه دعوه قضائي للتخلف
عن سداد تخيلوا ايش ايجار مكتب لها في
مدينه سان فرانسيسكو بمبلغ تافه قياسيا
طبعا بثروه ماسك حتى مع انخفاضات تخيلوا
القضيه بتتعلق فقط ب 135,000 دولار مش
مليون الف دولار بالاضافه الى اموال
مستحقه لم تتفاعل تويتر لتاجيرها رحلتي
طيران شركه كولومبيا رايت الملكه للمساحه
المكتبيه المؤجره لشركه ووتر رفع دعوى
ايضا قضائيه على الاخيره في منتصف الشهر
الماضي وعلى الرغم من الشركه الملكه
لتويتر خمسه ايام لدفع المبلغ لا الا انه
تويتر لغايه الان ما سددوا على كل حال
نحكي اكثر عن الموضوع معنا من الرياض عبد
الله السبع المحرر التقني في اندبندنت
عربيه اهلا بك يا عبد الله معنا في
تفاعلكم يعني عنجد شيء صعب انه الانسان
يفهموا شركه تويتر بجلاله قد هو والهن
ماسك بالم 137 مليار اللي بيملكههم مش
قادرين يدفعوا 135,000 دولار يعني كيف
نستوعب
لازم نعرف معلومه ان قيمه ثروت الى الناس
ليست كلها اموال كاش انما بعضها اسهم
بعضها
اكثر من 155
نعرف ان تويتر كيان مفصول عن له الناس في
الفلوس اللي موجوده عندي لا يعني انا اقدر
اصرفها على تويتر ايضا لازم نعرف معلومه
همم ان خلال الفتره الماضيه تويتر كانت
تمر بعده تاييرات اشخاص فصلوا من مناصبهم
همم تغييرات جدا كثيره في التاثيرات من
هذا النوع شيء جدا طبيعي لان شركه ترى تمر
بتغييرات جدا كثيره وموظفين تقريبا ما
يحضر للرقم لكن تقريبا ما يقرب الخمسين في
المئه الموظفين كانوا مو موجودين هذا ممكن
يزيد الضغط على الشركه وممكن يخلي في ضعف
بالتواصل ما بين الشركات عدد كبير من
الشركات همم
وسيله تواصل مع تويتر فمثلا الى اي شركه
كان عندها مثلا علاقه مع تويتر كانت
تتواصل معها خلال سنوات الماضيه قد الان
تمر بفتره انها ما تقدر تتواصل معه تويتر
بسبب انها ما تعرف من الموظفين اللي
موجودين داخل شركه فلذلك الموضوع حق
مكتبات وغيرها اتوقع انه راح يحل بفتره
جدا قريبه بسبب قله الموظفين وبسبب ايضا
همم عدم وجود اناس كثير في شركه بجانب
تغييرات الكبيره رجعت تمر فيها الشركه
لازم نعرف ان شركه غير جلدها بشكل كامل
غيرت موظفين فسرت موظفين جابت موظفين جدد
فاسقاطات من هذا النوع ومشاكل من هذا
النوع جدا متوقعه همم يعني اكيد تويتر
قادره راح تسدد المبلغ خلال فتره جدا
قريبه لكنه عادي ترى جدا يعرفوني عليهم
اجاره ههه بسبب منه الموظفين اساس المكان
موجودين وايضا بشكل استلام الاخطار
القانوني شكله فما حدش عارف بالموضوع
هو ممكن واحد سلمى وفصل من بكره ف ترى شيء
طبيعي جدا اللي قاعد تمر في فتره تويتر
واتوقع لانه حسب ما قرات انه كمان وصلت
تغيير الى الممثلين القانونيين وشغلات جدا
كثيره في الفتره الماضيه
فالوضع طبيعي جدا واتوقع انها رحت حل هذه
المساله خلال الفتره قريبه لكنه الفتره
التي تمر فيها تويتر فتره صعبه جدا على
الجميع فكره صعبه جدا على المتعاقدين معها
فتره صعبه جدا على كمان مستخدمين تويوتا
يعني الاخبار اللي بتظلها تطلع لهم ماسك
شو بيعمل عماله بتويتر تسريحه الموظفين
والقوانين الجديده وبعدين يعني مرفوع
عليها قضيه مبلغ تافه بغض النظر عن
الاسباب اللي كنت عم نتحدث عنها قديش هذا
بياثر على ثقه همم
مستخدمين تويتر
اول شيء لازم نعرف انه مستخدمين تويتر
حاليا على شقين شق متحمس جدا للمنصه وهذا
ما ادى الى زياده كمان اعداد المستخدمين
في المنصه ترى في الفتره الماضيه كانت في
طفره ونمو جدا كبير في اعداد المستخدمين
الجدد للمنصه لكن بنفس الوقت في ناس
مشتاقين من القرارات اللي قاعد تصير
مشتاقين لكل شيء لكن اذا رجعت لتجربه
المستخدم داخل المنصه المستخدم العادي
تويتر تحسن في الفتره الماضيه صار في تحسن
في تجربه المستخدم صحيح انك كانت في مشاكل
خاصه للمستخدمين عندنا في السعوديه قبل
تقريبا ثلاث اسابيع من راينا ثلاث اسابيع
صعبه اي احد يطلع من المنصوره ما يقدر
يدخل عليها كانت في مشاكل تقنيه موجوده
فيها لكن المستقبل باذن الله راح لكم مشرق
لمنصه خاصه ان الان في تطلعات الى مشاريع
جديده تطلعات الى افكار جديده قد تضاف
للملف عكس السابق في السابق للاسف كنا
نسمع المشاكل تمر فيها المنصه عن اخبار
زائفه عن حسابات وغيرها لكن انا وجهه
الشخصيه اتوقع ان المستقبل مشرق والمشاكل
في البدايه تكون وارده خاصه اذا كان في
شخص يشتغل ويحاول يغير الدماء داخل
المنظومه ان شاء الله يعني بنتمنى ذلك
لانه من الواضح بانه في كثير ناس مخلصين
لهذه المنصه لانه رغم همم يعني خروج كثير
من المص- منصات المشابهه لا العلن ولنور
مثل همم تنسوش او توتو وكمان بايرلر
وغيرها ما قدروا يحققوا اي نجاح بالمقارنه
همم تويتر فاكيد يعني بنتمنى انه بالفعل
همم المستقبل يكون مشرق اكتر وانه يكون في
محل له هي عبد الله شكرا جزيلا لك عبد
الله السبع المحرر التقني في عندي عربيه
كان معنا من الرياض